- Je ne suis pas capable de vous
dire ce qu'il en est exactement,
- Ce que je peux vous dire que
ma tête quand je l'ai connu,
c'est quelqu'un qui est très
bien performé surtout c'est un
athlète exemplaire sur toute la
ligne dans le sens d'aider ses
joueurs et de mettre la lumière
sur les autres.
En ce moment il demandait
l'aide, ça demande beaucoup de
courage. Ce sont des modèles
nous athlète et ils sont encore
de plus grands athlètes de
grands modèles qui sont capables
de démontrer leur vulnérabilité
derrière cette armure là qu'on
les connaît comme s'ils étaient
investis.
Ils ne sont pas ils sont comme
tous au fond.
- Dans l'histoire du sport, -
peut-être du
demander de l'aide et que ça ne
se faisait pas l'époque. C'était
vu comme étant une scène de
faiblesse
qu'est-ce qui a changé dans le
monde du sport pour que ça soit
maintenant permis à quelqu'un
même très grande dire : là j'ai
besoin d'une pause.
- Je pense que sa science dans
la société en général. Je pense
que les gens sont capables
maintenant de demander de l'aide
et d'en parler.
Je pense que c'est plus facile
que par le passé c'est la même
chose les accède au niveau.
Il y a plusieurs athlètes
probablement arrêtés leur
carrière à l'époque parce qu'il
y avait un manque de support.
Et de ne pas l'avoir dit, en ce
moment je salue tous les
athlètes qui récemment est
démontrée qu'effectivement c'est
difficile de vivre sous l'effet
de la rendre constamment et
d'être épié par des millions de
personnes à chaque fois qu'on
connaît des gestes et conseils
des choses.
Il faut dire aujourd'hui
compartiment avant les réseaux
sociaux sont très présent et
l'athlète est constamment
bombardé indirectement. Même
s'il ne veut pas d'être à l'abri
de s'éloigner de ça.
Ça démarre quand même ils sont
beaucoup plus esthétiques de son
époque.
- MONSIEUR Guilleman, moi
j'estime que parce qu'on entend
beaucoup évidemment depuis ce
midi c'est la pression, la
pression du public, la pression
des réseaux sociaux,
moi je ne suis pas sûr de ça je
pense que des champions à ce
niveau-là
c'est la pression qu'eux-mêmes
se mettent et il vivrait dans un
désert sans par la personne,
il voudrait gagner quand même et
il n'est jamais satisfait de ce
qu'il fait.
Je vois ça que plus comme une
dynamique intérieure que les
réseaux sociaux car Janja qui
dit n'importe quoi.
- C'est vrai Montréal c'est une
belle passe quand ça va bien.
C'est un peu plus difficile,
mais effectivement c'est
l'athlète mais cette pression.
C'est lui qui se dit : je veux
bien performer cet article
commence par son soliloque. Sa
conversation est en effet la
convulsion les aider.
La première chose effectivement
c'est qu'ils ont été exigeant
envers eux et il demeure
toujours. L'athlète ne veut
jamais voir ses performances
être réduite parce qu'il y a
quelqu'un d'autre qui attend
pour prendre sa place.
Donc effectivement, il y a une
pression qui se place à eux-
mêmes. Ce qui les amenait
jusque-là mais à l'occasion ça
devient un peu néfaste. Vous
avez totalement raison de sens
que ça commence par lui et notre
conversation.
Est-ce